Hey David, how can I stop drowning in email?
My email inbox is out of control.
It feels like I spent all day on email and
don't actually get my job done.
WTF.
Okay, so listen there, there are endless strategies
to deal with this.
A common, I'm not going to go through all
the ones that we hear, but a common one that
you hear is check email only at preset times,
check email at 9:00 AM and then 4:00 PM and
then that's it.
And then very often when people get that advice,
they will say, but in my job I'm not able
to do that.
Now, a lot of times the people who say in
my job, I'm not able to do that.
They actually would be able to do it if they
really thought through a way to generate expectations
that you're not going to be on email all day,
but this is a real problem.
There are lots of jobs where 50 60 70% of
the day is going to just keeping up with email
rather than actually doing the value generation
of the job.
So let me concede to you.
You are in one of those jobs where you can't
just check email a few a couple of times a
day or something like that.
I have successfully cut down my email time.
I would estimate by 75 or 80% with a very
simple three step strategy.
Okay.
The strategy is auto filtering, manual triaging,
and then batch processing.
Okay.
It sounds complicated.
It's not complicated at all.
All right.
First you start with auto filtering.
Any for, I'll talk about for me, you apply
this to yourself.
I'm on a bunch of different newsletters that
contain articles I might want to read or are
stories that might be good for the show.
I've got wrap-up services of what happened
on, you know, what happened on Fox news, all
these different things.
So I can pick things that I want to use for
the show.
Uh, anything related to, we get all sorts
of emails, I mean thousands and thousands
of emails every month about people's membership
payments that came in, people's membership
payments that failed, new subscriptions, cancellations,
all that stuff.
Everything I just listed gets auto filtered
into folders.
All of my newsletter services are automatically
filtered into an out of my inbox and into
a folder.
Everything that's membership related gets
filtered into a separate folder.
I never see that stuff in my inbox.
That is 90% of my email right there.
Great.
I'm nine tenths of the way there.
Then you've got to manually triage.
Okay.
I go through email more often than some people
and maybe I don't need to, but we do have
things that come up with the production of
the show.
Tech issues might have to be in touch with
affiliates or sales issues where I need to
get involved in like a, you know, figuring
out whether an advertiser is a good fit for
it for us or not or something like that.
So I need to see if those urgent things come
in.
But those take under 30 seconds to respond
to.
Okay.
And what my goal is is I never want to look
at an email more than two times.
I look at it the first time, can I answer
this email in under 30 seconds if it even
needs a response?
If the answer is yes, I do it.
Some people say you do your ten second responses,
everything else gets triaged.
If the email takes more than 30 seconds for
me to answer, I asked myself, does this have
to be done today or does this have to be done
this week?
If it's longer than this week, I file it and
put a note in my calendar to revisit it when
it needs to be revisited.
If it's an email that needs to be dealt with
today, I move it to a folder called today.
If it's something that needs to be done this
week, I move it to a folder called this week
and then at the end of the day I'll go to
my today folder and one after the other deal
with every email that had to be answered today
I'm condensing the email answering periods
of the day drastically.
Anything that's under 30 seconds that really
is of a more urgent nature, even though we
could debate whether it's really that urgent
or not, uh, it gets answered right away.
And then I look at my auto filtered stuff,
membership emails, those newsletters, articles,
stuff like that.
Once a day or every other day or whatever,
this has cut down to 75% on the time I spend
on email.
That's my suggestion.
There are services that can also help with
this stuff.
There are some services that will gather similar
types of emails and keep them out of your
inbox until you want them delivered.
You might say, deliver these at 4:30 PM and
then you get them all at once.
For example, I've not found the need to use
those services, but I know people who have
found them useful.
That is my approach.
Critique it, use whatever of it might be useful
for you, reduce the amount of time you're
spending on email because listen, I want to
be spending time researching stuff for the
show, generating value, creating content,
and when I cut down my email, 75% uh, I'm
drastically increasing the amount of time
I can spend on just making the best possible
show.
We've got a great bonus show coming up for
you today.
Make sure to sign up at David pakman.com/membership
or at patrion.com/david Pakman show.
I'll speak to you then the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].